hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar advancing
cellular ultrastructure research with
freeze fracture
and freeze etching i'm alexis corrales
of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar
is brought to you by labberds and
sponsored by leica microsystems
to learn more please visit their website
at leicamicrosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you you may also submit any technical
issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar webinar is educational and
thus offers
free continuing education credits please
click
on the continuing education window at
located at the bottom center of the
screen
to obtain your credits i'd like to now
welcome our two speakers for today
evan christophiac em staff scientist at
vanderbilt university
cell imaging shared resource core
facility
and seth villarreal advanced workflow
specialist
nanotechnology at leica microsystems
gentlemen welcome evan you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for that introduction today
i'd like to tell you about a technique
near and dear to my heart freeze
fracture and freeze etching
this talk will be broken down into three
parts
first part is a general overview of
freeze fracture and freeze etching
going over the general principles when
you would use free fracture when you use
freeze etching
and the workflow involved in producing
these replicas
second part will have some real world
applications of studies that i've done
that have used either freeze fracture
freeze etch
our cloud and strand morphologies
looking at tight junction strands by
freeze fracture
and the enteric glycocalyx architecture
which we use
extensive presentation for
and then the third part will concern
optimizing the replica images themselves
so it'll be some general guidelines on
how to produce very high quality
replicas and the second part will
concern a
optimization technique that i developed
to improve the biological fidelity of
replicas themselves
start with freeze fracture grease
fracture is character
or is characterized by physically
fracturing frozen samples along their
lipid bilayers
and this will produce images of either
the
extracellular or cytoplasmic face
leaflets including the membrane proteins
so i've got a couple examples to show of
what these kind of
images look like from freeze fracture so
at the top
we have a cell that's been fractured and
we can actually see the interior of the
cell here so we have a lot of cytoplasm
and there's a lot of vesicle trafficking
going on and then here we actually have
the
cytoplasmic leaflet the cell with a lot
of membrane proteins in it
including a very expensive type junction
which is located here
down here in this middle image we
actually have an um
much higher magnification image of what
these tight junction strands actually
look like
so this is again the cytoplasmic leaflet
and we can see
these tight junction strands throughout
it
and down here is another example this is
a
red blood cell leaflet
showing how many proteins are actually
present within the red blood cell
membrane
now freeze fracture is very useful for
biological details
of cells but it can also be used to
characterize other
structures such as exosomes and
liposomes
the uh the advantage of using uh freeze
fracture technique
for these kind of samples is they will
be well preserved so you won't have
the same kind of artifacts that you
would observe
in a dried sample like a negative stain
so let's go over how freeze fracture is
actually done
in principle so you have a frozen sample
that is in a crease fracture apparatus
on a cryo stage
crowd stage is typically kept around
-110
but that temperature can vary depending
on what your exact goals are
and we have two
deposition sources a carbon source and a
metal
shadowing source and a cold micro tone
blade that is kept as cold as possible
typically that's around -180 but
sometimes you can do a little bit better
so we used that blade to actually
fracture the cell
hopefully along the lipid bilayers
once the cell has been fractured we want
to kind of rapidly
produce a metal shadow from an angle for
freeze fracture we typically do
unidirectional shadowing
at a 45 degree angle so unit directional
means there's no rotation in the stage
so we're angling just from one
side and this will produce a really nice
shadowing effect that is easy to
interpret most of the time as soon as
that
platinum has been deposited we want to
stabilize the whole replica with a layer
of carbon
and this is done from the top if you do
not stabilize
these the replica with carbon it would
actually just fall apart because it
wouldn't have any cohesion
so the carbon is deposited typically
with rotation to make sure you get a
nice even coating
let's go on to freeze etching so freeze
etching is a similar technique
to freeze fracture but it's mostly used
to look at things outside the membrane
or maybe attach to the membrane
but not within the leaflet itself so
freeze etching is characterized by
sublimating water off a frozen sample
and then creating a replica of that
surface
it often still includes fracture to make
sure that we have
cut into the tissue or the cell to the
correct depth
but the technique is really
characterized by looking at
at these kind of external or internal
structures so i have a couple examples
here
this top image is the mouse glycocalyx
on the small intestine so these are
microvilli this looks like
calyx which is this extensive meshwork
structure that sticks out
here we have a variant of freeze etching
called unroofing
cell and looping and what we're looking
at here
is actually the inside of the membrane
from the cell perspective this is a
clathrin-coated pit
visualized from the inside and down here
we have
this is the luminal surface of bladder
epithelium
showing on this uh kind of crystalline
protein array that exists on the
surface called it's uh uroplax proteins
so this can also be used uh this
technique freeze etching can also be
used very extensively for
exosomes liposomes again this would be
looking at the surface of these
instead of looking inside or even
hydrogels
the calyx is sort of an example of a
naturally produced hydrogel gel
that exists in in the intestine so
hydrogels often suffer from dehydration
artifacts
typically if you want to look at it by
sem or tm you're going to have to
remove the water when you do this by a
chemical dehydration such as
the details and this can be problematic
so let's go over how you do freeze
touching somewhat similar workflow
so we start with the same kind of idea
you have your cell
it's that -110 we have our cold blade
the e-beam for the
platinum shadow is now at a different
angle and we'll go over that
in a minute so we're going to fracture
our sample you can actually fracture
above your sample in this case if you
would like
i typically aim to hit a little bit on
the sample
and rather than have the microtone
immediately clear
the sample to do the metal shadowing in
this case we're going to leave the cold
blade
over the sample and then warm the sample
up just a little bit
to minus 100 c now the temperature
temperature differential between the
sample
and the cold blade along with the vacuum
it's going to cause water to leave the
sample
and get attracted to the knife blade and
depending on how long you do this you
can get either a very shallow etch
so that would be maybe five minutes to
very deep etching which can go up to 30
minutes
so once the water is supplemented off
the sample we'll move the blade
and then we will deposit the metal at an
angle
typically i like to do this with rotary
shadowing so the sample is rotating
and we will do this at a lower angle so
with rotary shadowing it's often ideal
to
reduce this angle to get a little bit
better detail especially
in going for details of these extras
extracellular structures so once the
platinum has been deposited
we do uh carbon stabilization again
and this is just to hold the replica
together and now we have a complete
sample
now what do you do when you have this
done well here's the whole workflow
so to start with you need to have a
frozen sample and it needs to be in
vitreous ice
you cannot do freeze fracture freeze on
a sample with ice crystals it will look
extremely poor
so your options are typically high
pressure freezing or slam freezing
both have their advantages and
disadvantages
pressure freezing will work very well
and freeze your sample all the way
through often with vitreous ice but
doesn't work on all samples
slime freezing on the other hand is
pretty consistent but will only freeze
about 10 microns
of depth so not nearly the depth you can
get with the high pressure freezer
now you can freeze in other media
provided that you get
using other machines is provided you get
actual vitreous ice
one way of doing this without this
equipment is to
cryoprotect so you can fix samples
infiltrate them with a cryo protection
for freeze fracturing glycerol works
really well
and then you can plunge freeze in
something like liquid ethane
that's a little bit more accessible but
you lose a lot of the advantages of
freezing live
and getting the biological context of
your tissue
so once you have your frozen samples you
need to transfer
them to the freeze fracture apparatus
and you need to maintain them in their
vitreous state without contamination
then we go through the process we just
described so the fracture or etch
and depositing the metals and then we
have a couple
options so my preferred option is to
image on the tem
because it's higher resolution but
before you can do that
you need to remove the um
the cells and tissue from the sample so
we actually only want to image that
that metal and carbon film because we
won't be able to image throughout the
tissue itself
so typically this is done by floating
the whole sample on
bleach for quite a while until all the
sample is removed you can also float on
hydrofluoric acid if
your sample is on a cover slip to
dissolve the glass and then after some
washes float on bleach
so that's how to get to the tem now if
you have a cryo sem you can actually do
a direct transfer
between the freeze fracture apparatus
and the cryo sem
and the advantage to this is that your
whole sample will definitely remain
intact and you'll have good biological
context for your imaging
the disadvantage is you won't have the
same resolution you would have in the tm
all right so let's move on to the second
part these are the real world
applications
some studies have done we're going to
start with
tight junctions so tight junctions are
a cellular feature that exists between
or
exists in epithelial and endothelial
cells
it is a network of ceiling strands right
at the apical surface
that serves to moderate the ion flow
between the apical and basal side
of the cell this is essential for a lot
of different things including blood
brain barrier
proper intestinal function proper
hearing there's
quite a few examples
the main constitution the main protein
involved in
tight junctions are cloudings and
these are what actually physically form
these strands
now these strands can be observed by a
variety of different techniques
we can use confocal with a cloud and
that's tagged with the gfp for example
or you could antibody label
and we get images like this showing that
there is a tight junction here but we
don't have a lot of details beyond that
you can also look at them by tem this is
two enterocytes in the small intestine
um it's the apical surface right here
and we can see the dijunction
but again we're not getting a lot of
details about what that structure
actually
looks like so let's look at it by press
fracture
so this is images of the cloudin 15
strand
structure so in these images we can see
a lot more details than we could by
confocal or
conventional tem in this case we're
seeing
that there are multiple strands in a
tight junction they are curved
they can either have a gentle curve
shown here
or these really kind of quick
deflections and they can also branch
so these are all details that would not
be observable without freeze fracture
so in the study shown here we did a lot
of characterization
of how these strands can bend flex and
branch
and we're able to characterize sort of
some of how that that works in the
strands
now also this this figure shows a very
important thing which is the difference
between the leaflets
so this is the p phase this is the
cytoplasmic face
of the leaflet and this is where the
proteins tend to segregate to during
a fracture so all the strands are in the
p phase
the e face on the other hand which is
the extracellular phase
will tend to have these grooves in it
and this is where the proteins were
but they're no longer present i find the
p-phase easier to analyze than the
e-phase but both are valid
so one of the major questions about um
tai junctions is sort of how they are
built
so in 2014 suzuki had all published in
science
the first structure of a cloud and
monomer this is the cloud m15 monomer
and this set off a whole series of
studies and how this monomer is
assembled into this strand-like
structure
so this same group proposed a um
structure that was rather complicated uh
between that that shows how the
cloudiness are assembled
both between cells and in a single cell
so
the tight junctions themselves are
actually always between two cells so it
can get a little confusing to image his
cell one membrane
cell two membrane and the cloudiness
themselves have
a trans interaction so trans means trans
cellular
interaction now if we look at the same
structure kind of from a top view down
instead we can see um what the structure
looks like in their model and this
actually has two different
interactions that we call cis
interactions because they're in the same
membrane
so we have a cis interaction along the
strand you can kind of imagine the
strand growing
this way and then a second interaction
that occurs across the strand
so we were very interested in validating
this
interface here that was proposed by this
group
so we started by looking at the crystal
structure
and what residues were proposed to
interact in the previous study
and that was the um methionine 68 and
quantum 15 with the
phenylalanine 146 147 now this 146 147
are well known to be important and if
you mutate those strands do not form
however when we examine this methionine
we found that
actually when you mutate it to either
alanine or glutamic acid it doesn't
really make a difference in strand
formation
so we can see by confocal that we have
anti junctions forming
in these cells and then when we do the
freeze fracture on these cells we can
see that the strands themselves look
pretty similar to the wild type
so it suggests that this particular
residue is not that important
so this sent us back to kind of look at
what might be going on here
and what what this interface might also
kind of imply and the flexibility we saw
in the strands
so we did some analysis on the residue
residues involved in the um
the interface here and we found that
there are actually some very conserved
residues among all the different cloud
ends suggesting they're probably
important
in the interface we also found that if
you rotate this interface a little bit
from the crystal structure
that you get a kind of a more
energetically favorable interaction
this might be a good mechanism for how
this transaction bend
so from our analysis we determined that
the serine 67
right next to the methionine 68 it's
probably pretty important because it's
forming
hydrogen bonds along with this glutamic
157 on the adjacent cloudiness
so we set out to kind of do the same
type of
mutagenesis to see if these residues
were important
and actually they all formed um no
matter what mutation we made they all
formed
tight junctions on the confocal level so
if we left it about it would be kind of
a really boring story that we did these
mutations
we analyzed them by confocal and we
weren't able to see very much
however in freeze fracture the strand
morphology changes quite a bit
so here's our wild type strands again so
this is p face up here we have a little
bit of e phase just to show you the
grooves
if we mutate that serine to an alanine
we end up going from these nice
continuous strands in the p
phase to kind of a broken strand
morphology that mixes between the p
face and e phase similar to the glutamic
acid when we take that
we also get a broken morphology and
this is probably the most interesting
part of the study we can actually swap
these two residues so the sarin to
glutamic acid glutamic acid
serine and uh
that will actually form a normal looking
strand network which is really kind of
cool if you do the single mutations they
still have the broken morphology
so this suggests this is sort of a
rescue by maintaining the same
interaction just swapping which
cloudiness doing the
interaction with the other so this
um the fact that they still form
junctions but they're disrupted suggests
that this
is a cis interface that's important but
probably not the only cis interface
that exists it's probably a second one
that's allowing the strands to at least
partially form that we can detect by
tyjunction or by
freeze fracture or by confocal that's
probably that
inner second cyst interaction that we
saw across the strand
we'll revisit that in a little bit
let's move on to the second study this
is a concerning the enteroglycocalyx
so glycocalyx is a glycoprotein covering
that surrounds
or is on the apical surface of epithelia
and endothelial cells
and also can coat bacteria and in all
three cases it often serves to act as
sort of a
protective barrier to these cells from
their outside environment
now the enterocytes like calyx is
primarily composed of
mucins so we use that term kind of
interchangeably glycocalyx and mucin
but these things are actually
notoriously difficult to
uh to image so we can image them by
confocal again
and this is done typically by doing
immunolabeling
so we can label with uh we germa gluten
in and this sort of just labels the
sugars in the mucins
or we can actually use a new antibody in
this case
um lesion 17 and we can get some details
we can detect that these structures
exist on top of microvilli which are
labeled
here with floydin but we can't really
get an idea of what this structure
actually looks like we can't even really
get dimensions on it
now if we try and look for this like
calyx by
an em method you actually have a lot of
difficulty
so here's sem of an enterocyte kind of
fracture didn't have
this is not freeze fracture this is just
sem fracture
and if we look on top of the microvilli
we don't see
much of anything similarly if we look at
pre-substituted enterocytes and
tem we get this haze above the
microvilli but no definitive structure
nothing
certain so let's see what this looks
like by presetch
when we present this structure
something quite striking so we have our
enterocyte
microbili and then on top of that
we have this kind of huge glycocalyx
structure that sits on top of all these
microbi
and if you look it's almost the same
size as the microvilli
cells let's compare that again to the
sem
image which doesn't show anything if we
were to go by the sem image you would
assume that the microvilli are actually
there
when in fact this large structure exists
on top of the
[Music]
microphilia what can we do with this
kind of
imaging you can actually learn a lot
about how this glycocalyx functions
with the enterocyte so just from this
image we were able to
determine that there are several
extracellular vesicles
that appear kind of in the glycocalyx
themselves
they they may be going or coming we
don't know
but they are sort of trapped in here for
now we can see that where the mucins
leave the microbial eye is a different
location
than where the catheter and
proto-coherent links are that bind the
microphilia together
so more the mucins are more apical
really just from the tip where they kind
of fan out
and interact with each other we're also
able to look at the
musin glycocalyx network and kind of
characterize
some of its sort of filter functions by
looking at
the the mesh size so this is sort of the
pores that form in between
this kind of complicated strand
structure
and this is where you could get a
comparison to something like a hydrogel
and we also were able to see how this
mesh structure actually kind of forms
so the strands or the filaments of the
calyx kind of merge together and branch
away
at various the um the whole structure
to create these kind of void openings
that we call
the mesh this occurs in um
just multiple different ways we can also
see that the filaments themselves
actually have different widths and this
suggests there's multiple museums
involved which isn't too
surprising
and then at the top is a really kind of
astounding feature
so at the very top of the calyx we have
what we call the termini
so these are the ends of the filaments
and one of the most striking
features of the termini
is that they all kind of end at the
exact same plane
and if we look at them each one has a
little dot and they're actually
hexagonally packed from each other so we
can see that here with just our eyes we
can also do a fourier transform
and kind of show that in more detail so
we were able to show that this term and
i
all basically have the same nearest
neighbor distance and they're packed
very
very um very carefully suggesting that
while we have kind of chaos below with
the strands coming together
and coming apart there's a lot of order
actually in the system itself
the other interesting thing with these
termini is they are very resistant to
water sublimation during the etching
process we think this is because they're
highly decorated with sugars and kind of
hold on to their water
very strongly so
presetching allowed us to visualize all
these structures that were previously
pretty difficult to see or understand
and now we have an idea of how this
kind of unique structure on the
enterocytes actually functions
um we're able to build a model of it
actually so here we have the
microvilli with their links holding them
together
and above that we have this dense
network that we think
serves as sort of a size exclusion
filter in a way
and on top we have this
termini that all are on the same plane
and probably act as more of a protective
function to protect the entire site
below
all right let's move on to optimizing
replicas
so first let's start with some general
guidelines
so first of all most important thing
when making any sample really is that
start with something high quality
so this means that the the sample was
healthy
beforehand it did not degrade over time
and either it was fixed well before
you know you you froze it or you can
actually fast freeze
you're in a fast freeze and high
pressure freezer for example
it's best to kind of get that sample
out of the the animal or tissue culture
whatever is going on
and into the highest freezer as quickly
as possible
for a lot of things this can be done on
the order of seconds if you're really
good
and this will preserve everything the
actual way it is so you get the highest
level of kind of temporal detail nothing
is degraded yet
it's also really important to get good
ice so it has to be in vitreous ice if
there are ice crystals they will look
very poor
and it's really not even worth
fracturing
and the second part is where a lot of
problems often occur
so while we're supplementing water away
and etching we actually don't want a lot
of water to get into the freeze
fracture apparatus so in general it's
good to avoid humidity with any cryo
workflow and this is especially case for
freeze fracture
and sometimes you can avoid and
sometimes you can't in tennessee it's a
very humid environment
we uh we run dehumidifiers to reduce the
humidity as much as possible
but there is still some the second part
is not allowing essentially air
into your your freeze fracture apparatus
when you insert the sample
so reducing that amount of contamination
is
very important it'll allow you to reach
higher vacuum quicker
and cause less problems with your
samples
and kind of along those lines too it's
very important to allow the
freeze fracture apparatus to reach high
vacuum before
starting a fracture etch this will
prevent
contamination of your samples from water
so
oftentimes the cold sample will attract
frost to it
and after you've done your fracture etch
if you get frost on your sample
it will be preserved in the replica and
look quite poor
so it's important to avoid that kind of
along those lines it's really important
that as soon as you're done fracturing
or etching to actually form that replica
without any delay
so as soon as that blade is off the
sample the
metal evaporation should start
now let's go on to metal shadowing
so the optimum angle and whether you
have rotation or not varies
greatly between samples in general
the lower the angle of the the metal
shadow you can get greater detail
of your sample but if you have a lot of
topography in your sample you're going
to end up with large regions that aren't
shadowed at all
and you will have difficulty analyzing
those um
additionally whether you do a rotary
shadow or unidirectional shadow will
greatly change how you're able to
interpret different structures
for example tight junction strands are
almost always unidirectional shadowed
because it makes it easier to understand
what the strand looks like but freeze
thatcher often rotary shadow
in general i like 45 degrees
unidirectional shadow for freeze
fracture
and for freeze etching more like
rotary shadow for sure and maybe 20
degrees
it's something that you have to play
around with a little bit to optimize
all right let's get into
optimization of replicas for biological
fidelity
so we're going to go into a technique i
developed to
preserve maximum amount of biological
detail but this is
at the expense of contrast and we'll
kind of go through this
so what we're actually imaging when
we're imaging these kind of samples
we're not
imaging the biological surface itself
we're imaging the replica of the
biological surface
this is primarily the metal evaporation
at a shadow that we're
we're imaging so if the metal does not
accurately
preserve the details of the biological
surface then we can't see it
in the electron microscope and
typically we use platinum platinum is a
very good metal for this because it
forms very small grains
but it does still form grains in fact
any pure metal that you deposit on a
biological cold sample is going to form
crystals and we can actually see them if
you look carefully you might be able to
see
some platinum lattice planes in this
image there's a very high magnification
of the
junction strand we do the fourier
transform of this image we can see these
spatial frequencies and we can actually
characterize these spatial frequencies
and find they they correspond very well
to
platinum uh crystal planes
so the crystallization of the platinum
is interfering with our ability to
resolve biological details we did this
similarly with the
luminal surface of the bladder
epithelium this has that europlacan and
2d crystal that's a very useful tool
for understanding resolution
here we did a rotary shadow and here's
the europlaquin complex
see they should all actually be
completely uniform to one another
but we can see that the the platinum did
not deposit uniformly and this is again
due to crystallization
so we thought what can we make replicas
out of
that would not crystallize and there's
one answer that's fairly obvious that we
tried which is just to use amorphous
carbon
so in this case we're just cutting out
the platinum shadow completely
and we're actually shadowing a little
bit with carbon instead but mostly this
is carbon from overhead
so we have the luminal surface of the
bladder again just as a resolution
test so these are all 2d crystals and
that allows us to use the fourier space
to kind of figure out how much
biological fidelity we have so over here
we have freeze that
used rotary shadow platinum replica
showing the uh the surface and here this
is the same
replica three times using amorphous
carbon instead
using different imaging techniques
so the uh the platinum replica is kind
of limited to about three nanometers
resolution
and that's just a hair property of the
platinum crystals
when we look at the carbon we don't have
a lot of contrast
in fact when we're near focus since
there's very little amplitude contrast
there's almost no no nothing to image at
all although if we look in the fourier
space we can see there's actually quite
a bit of biological detail there
spatial frequencies extend quite far we
can
apply some phase contrast techniques
either
using defocus which is sort of the
conventional way of
adding some phase contrast in tm or we
can use a face plate
and get some additional details out of
these samples
and what we see is that we get spatial
frequencies that extend quite a bit
further
up to i think in this case it's 1.8
nanometer but we've actually gotten
smaller as well
we can take these spatial frequencies
and actually filter on them
and kind of get rid of the noise in the
image when we do that we can see the
platinum
um sample actually looks pretty nice but
only the central core of the
europlacement is really getting shadow
probably has something to do with the
topography along with the
crystallization
of the platinum when we look at the
carbon on the other hand we're able to
resolve a lot more details of this
complex
however there is very little contrast so
that's
an issue using the carbon replicas
we thought it might be interesting to
try and overcome
this lack of contrast using a kind of a
single particle approach
similar to what's done in cryo tm
and so in that case we looked at
connexin 26 which is a gap junction
protein
and here we have just a freeze fracture
carbon replica of connection 26
and what we did is just picked all the
particles in this one image
and then did some alignment and
averaging and we were able to
get this image out of it keep in mind
this is just
this many particles here um and we're
able to see this kind of star shape
in the center of the connection and
also some of the outside detail out here
this is sort of the carbon shadow this
dark region
when we fit that with the crystal
structure of connection 26 we find it
actually fits quite well
now this technique is quite limited in
replicas
to use to use single particle because we
only really have one view
can only see them from the top down so
it's not like you can do a full 3d
reconstruction
but it does have utility and
understanding how
how some of these proteins fit into a
greater biological context
so we also went back to this tight
junction architecture with this
new technique and what we're interested
in this time
was not this interaction which we felt
was pretty well
studied at that point but instead
whether
this across
a cross-strand interaction is actually
occurring
so no one has been able to kind of
confirm this by with any direct evidence
mutations in this interface often cause
the strands to fail to form but that
doesn't necessarily prove much
so we were interested if we could
actually
resolve that there was a space between
these two
transmembrane regions and the tight
junction strands
so he's carbon replicas for that well
here first i'm going to show you
um platinum replica of
a single ti ti-junction strand so strand
is here
and we can see a lot of uh crystalline
lattice planes from the
platinum but we can't see a double
double structure at all it's just not
present we think that's because the
biological resolution of platinum
replicas is just not
good enough to resolve this small of a
structure
so we use carbon replicas instead using
some phase contrast techniques
and we're actually able to show that
there is um looks like two lines
in a single strand and the lines are
about four nanometers apart
and so that gave us a good amount of
confidence
that these cloud and strands which are
also about four nanometers apart
are probably actually this double
stranded versus a single stranded you
can actually
resolve that there's probably a
difference between what a single strand
would look like versus two
and they all appear to be two
all right with that i just have some
acknowledgements so first i would like
to acknowledge my
postdoc advisor bashar kashar and all my
co-authors
that were at nib cd when we published
those studies
and then i would like to acknowledge
vanderbilt university and sell
imaging shared resource core facility
where i work now
the the management of the salomon
chair resource matissica jenny schaefer
and j jerome
as well as people i work with every day
maria rachel and mary with that i will
hand it over
to seth
thank you evan my name is seth
villarreal i'll be talking
briefly on the ace 900 which is an
automated freeze fracture system that
can assist in the type of workflows that
evan
just presented on
the high vacuum workflows
that can benefit
the ability to load samples under vacuum
on a cryo stage
and then carry out freeze fracture and
freeze etch
in a controlled dedicated environment
the loading interface allows samples to
be picked up
either through a manual system or
through the vct500 shuttle
allowing the sample to be worked with in
a variety of different ways
keeping a sample preserved throughout
the entire workflow
is a critical part in maintaining its
sample integrity
the load lock system on the a700
has a couple of different options on the
left of the image
was the docking port for the vcp500 on
the right
was for the manual transfer rod either
of these
allow a sound will be loaded onto the
cryo stage of the ace 900
letting you work in a vacuum up to five
ten to the minus eight millibar and this
cradle sage can operate at a temperature
down to negative 185
c
with the option of two e-beam emitters
the cryo stage can
tilt rotate and rock during coding
allowing the sample to be prepared for
any
workflow needed
the freeze fracture encoding
can be done either through a manual or
automated fracture
and even fracture into the beam end
the knife for freeze fracture can be
exchanged under vacuum
such that multiple samples can be
handled at once and maintained
in that very controlled environment
during evaporation the coating rate is
adjustable and it's possible to have
separate e beams for platinum carbon
coating
and pure carbon coating furthermore
working
with the samples there is an option for
camera or direct viewing
provide as much flexibility as possible
in trying to handle these delicate
workflows
the ace 900 is one of the machines
and leica's dedicated
instrument for carrying out freeze
fracture
and freeze edge thank you evan for the
chance to share your this particular
device and to hear about your work
at this point we'll be pausing to
answer any questions thank you everyone
thank you evan and seth for your
informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
are there ways to mark proteins or
complexes of interest
in preparation for freeze fracture
um i think i can answer that that's this
is evan
um so one way of marking
structures in increased fracture freeze
edge is to do
immunogold labeling this is a rather
tricky technique to do john rash has
some excellent papers describing the
technique
but essentially after the replica has
been formed in
the freeze fracture apparatus you would
digest away the tissue with something
like sds rather than bleach
in an attempt to keep some of the
membrane
proteins still attached to the replica
and then you can
immunoglobulable those attached proteins
and they kind of go in a more or less
standard workflow in the tem
and in that way you have whatever you
want to look at marked with the gold
you could probably also do this with
something like a quantum dot and do some
correlative
microscopy with it
great thank you so much evan it looks
like we've got another question for you
and this one
is two parts first part
is there any experimental demonstration
that etching does not facilitate
some collapse of fine uh for uh
fibrillar elements and the second
portion
is another way to or another way to ask
is this
has fftem glycocalyx been shown to have
the same
appearance of the of the fibrils as
hydrated atomic force microscopy
so that's a really good question um i
don't have a definitive answer on this
but i'll give you a couple
thoughts i have on it so we have looked
at various etchings
on the glycocalyx and if you over etch
so
this is just remove too much water the
glycocalyx does collapse
so we were trying to minimize the
etching to kind of get a single layer of
nuisance
that are still kind of supported by
vitreous ice on the back
for this study i think it would be
really interesting to look at it
through afm i don't know how you would
image from the side like that um
have to think about a way to kind of
section appropriately
but you could definitely look from the
top and look at the termini at the very
least
thanks evan our next question how
delicate are the replicas
and can etch samples be stored or
transported
so the replicas when they're being
floated
on on the bleach
to remove the tissue are extremely
delicate this is when
you can easily lose the sample so
the kind of the the thicker the replica
the more likely it is to hold together
but also you'll get less details um once
you've got them free of their tissue and
kind of collected them onto
em grids they are very robust and stable
you can keep them in a grid box for
years and they'll be fine
and our next question instead of pure
metal
have you been using any other types of
metals
well we have explored this um quite a
bit
um so the ideal or ideal
shadowing material would be something
with a high z
so that it scatters electrons to
amplitude contrast
and would also kind of accurately
replicate the biological surface so this
would kind of just
sit where it's deposited and not form a
crystal
now we found that basically any pure
metal is going to crystallize under
these conditions when deposited
so and especially known for things like
gold which are routinely
used for sem
but it is possible that a mixture of
metals to form an alloy
might be very suitable for this
and maybe some of the lighter metals may
work quite well as well but then you're
back to
phase contrast and you might as well
just be using carbon at that point
great thank you so much evan so we do
have another question that came in
that's a little bit of a long one so
so bear with me here the formation of
crystalline ptc
replicas seemed to be an unusual feature
of the eight
of the ace 900 which is of course not
desirable
this is not observed in other freeze
fracture machines
have you studied the techniques of john
rash to get a high level of
detail from the ptc freeze fracture
replicas
and could these methods or hardware
modification
be implemented in your in your hardware
um i i guess i can start with this and
then head off to step
so the crystalline formation of platinum
is is inherent
in all platinum carbon replicas it's
just not normally
imaged because you need a very high
magnification
to see it uh most of those replicas are
actually
developed or made on a balsa type
freeze fracture machine so probably
closer to something john rash is using
i know he gets very good replicas by
having very very good vacuum and
depositing much colder
and this will definitely produce better
results but you will get crystals no
matter
what you do if you're depositing a pure
metal
you know and i'll hand it off to seth
for any additional details here
seth do we still have you
it looks like we may have unfortunately
lost seth
but you know with unfortunately with
technical difficulties
um what we can do though is um
for for those of you that have asked
that question um
what we will do is we'll have seth reply
um
we will have him reply via via email to
you so we will be able to answer
you know the rest of your question off
of what evan has
already answered so we we apologize for
those technical difficulties
um so let's go to here
we've got another question um so evan i
believe this one will be for you
how can somebody tell if a freeze
fracture knife needs to be replaced
um well you will be able to tell because
your replica will start to
have marks in it from the knife so if
you see unnatural
kind of indentations in the replica and
maybe a cell or
something like that it's a good
indication that the knife needs to be
changed
thank you so much evan and it looks like
we may have time for
one more question why do you refer to
pure
excuse me why do you prefer refer to
pure
metal when it is a ptc shadow
okay that is absolutely correct that it
is a platinum carbon deposition
so the um e-beam actually has a carbon
crucible in it which has a piece of
platinum in it
and that's what deposits onto the sample
so i think it's something like
five percent carbon 95 platinum
an idea there is that the carbon works
to interfere with platinum
crystallization
kind of like how steel works um
and so that that that's the correct
terminology we just
say pure metal as kind of a general
terminology instead of like a mix of
different metals like an ally
great thank you so much evan so we want
to thank evan and seth
for their presentations today um
unfortunately since we did lose seth
evan do you have any final comments for
our audience
um refracture and freeze etching are
useful techniques
but they take a little bit of skill to
learn
so if you want to do these techniques
patience is required
duly noted thank you evan thank you
again evan and seth for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank labbert and our
sponsor
leica microsystems for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now until next time bye
bye everyone